[Music]
on this Tuesday night criminal charges
in a Quebec town after what police say
was a deliberate act the driver accused
of going on a rampage and a horror
haunting Witnesses high drama this
incident demonstrates a lack of
competence the U.S forced to ditch a
military drone and it blames Russian
fighter jets
clearing the Avalanche of complaints
against Airlines
ottawa's multi-million dollar plan to
help unhappy customers get their money
back and inspiring inclusion I always
knew that there is something different
in me the BC drag queen Paving a path
for the Punjabi queer community
Rubble National with Donna freezing good
evening and thanks for joining us a
driver of a pickup truck Who police say
deliberately struck pedestrians in a
Quebec town has been charged with two
counts of dangerous driving causing
deaths the accused a 38-year-old man who
lives in the community appeared in court
today lawyers say it's too early to say
anything about a motive or the
possibility of murder charges two men
were killed and nine others injured
including a baby and a toddler when they
were run down on the street yesterday
afternoon in amqui in Quebec's gas Bay
Region it's a small town and what's
happened has devastated people leaving
them asking why Mike Armstrong has our
top story tonight
memories of what happened on this street
will be hard for witnesses to shake one
who saw the pickup plowing into
pedestrians says people were flying
through the air like bowling pins
this witness says he saw a man go under
the pickup
that's what's stuck in my head he says
witness Ken Maho says everyone around
him was hit and the man beside him was
killed moho lives in M quit he just
passed a family on the sidewalk a woman
children in strollers and what appeared
to be grandparents when he heard a
commotion behind him he looked back and
saw the pickup drive through them
he says he can still hear the sound of
the truck accelerating he had only a
split second to jump out of the way now
according to that witness the truck
drove away but turned back about a
minute later it passed the scene again
with bodies lying on both sides of the
road from there police say the driver
went to the local Provincial Police
Station
Quebec spokesperson Claude says when the
suspect showed up he right away told
officers what he'd done 38-year-old
Steve gonyo is charged with two counts
of dangerous driving causing death other
charges are likely to be added ganyo is
from the area but doesn't appear to have
known the victims
gangyo appeared in court in am queen
Tuesday afternoon there were jeers
outside the courthouse and one of the
victims was
some of his friends were on hand to see
the suspect in person
I'd rather see him dead this man says
the tragedy has shocked the town and the
province it was only a few weeks ago
that a man drove a bus into a daycare
north of Montreal killing two the
incidents have left many questioning
whether enough is being done to help
people going through a mental health
crisis short-term crisis teams are being
brought into amqui to help people deal
with what they're going through now it
hit me hard yesterday I didn't know any
of those people but I mean
could have been me I always walk by
there could have been my mom could have
been you know
waved his right to a bail hearing within
three days he'll be back in court
instead April 5th he left without
commenting but police say he has been
collaborating with investigators they
just won't say how Mike Armstrong Global
News
prime minister Justin Trudeau has
offered his condolences to the
tight-knit community of amqui
we all have lots of questions but right
now we're just trying to be there for
survivors and families and we will
continue to be there as long as it takes
as they get through this difficult time
the Prime Minister also thanked First
Responders for acting quickly
courageously and professionally the U.S
says a Russian fighter jet harassed and
then collided with an unmanned American
drone over the Black Sea and what the
U.S calls an unsafe and unprofessional
intercept the U.S says the Drone was
conducting routine operations in
international airspace over the Black
Sea this morning says it was forced to
ditch The Reaper drone like this one in
the sea after one of two Russian fighter
jets tracking it hit a propeller the U.S
state department calls it a Brazen
violation of international law what we
what we saw again were fighter aircraft
dumping fuel in front of this UAV and
then getting so close to the aircraft
that it actually damaged the propeller
on the MQ-9
Russia has a different story saying its
fighter jets did not come into contact
with the Drone but that the Drone
maneuvered sharply and crashed Moscow
has repeatedly voiced concerns about U.S
intelligence flights close to the
Crimean Peninsula today Russia's
ambassador to the U.S said Russia does
want to avoid any unintended
consequences
containing confrontation between the
United States and Russian Federation we
are in favor of pragmatic relations
for the sake
for the interest of the people of the
United States and Russian Federation
in Ukraine civilians who volunteered to
fight and who have died for their
country were honored today
family and friends brought flowers and
Paws to mourn those who have died in the
fight against Russia President Vladimir
zielinski said he is grateful to
everyone who felt it was time to become
a warrior
we don't know exactly how many
ukrainians have been killed since the
invasion began but it's well into the
thousands Russian troops are dying too
and the intensity of the fight
especially around Bak moot is brutal
Russia has been trying to capture that
City for months in a grinding War of
Attrition as Crystal gemancing Reports
with Moscow closing in residents are
getting out
the fighting around Bak Moody is being
described as very tough and very painful
Ukrainian military officials and the
president say it's where the country's
future is being decided and Vladimir
zielinski's tone all but eliminates
speculation of a retreat
we need to destroy the enemy's military
might and we will
[Music]
despite months of Fierce and bloody
combat that hasn't happened yet Russian
forces alongside private mercenary group
Wagner have been pushing to seize
control of the city it's a critical
Supply route to the contested East Rob
Hubert is a Canadian military analyst as
we see the fighting the fighting is
intense zielinski does not want to be
seen as showing his retreating on any
aspect because then it basically the
narrative that the Russians are able to
put forward is yeah you know we will
persevere one seventy thousand people
lived in buckmood in the Donetsk region
a Ukrainian salt mining town
nearly nothing is left yet the
bombardment of it and neighboring
communities is Relentless
his mother and daughter from bakmut say
they only know of a 90 year old man and
their neighbor trying to stick it out
they're on their way to crematorsk with
a few others they'll make the hour-long
drive but their destination is not
immune to the ravages of the war one
person was killed Tuesday in a Russian
missile strike on the city's center six
high-rise buildings were damaged and
several people injured the real moment
of achievement for Putin is when he is
able to convince enough of the major
decision makers within the West that the
war can't be won
combating that seed of Doubt is part of
the reason Ukrainian officials have been
front and center speaking with world
leaders the West has been unified to
this point and the donated weapons
flowing to Ukraine are the Difference
Maker Crystal commencing Global News
London
the U.S the UK and Australia are banding
together to create a new Fleet of
nuclear-powered submarines intended to
counter the influence of China Canada
close Ally of all three countries has
chosen not to be part of it despite our
country's lack of sophisticated
submarines and our increasing
vulnerability around Arctic security
Redmond Shannon reports
three-fifths of the five eyes are
focusing underwater the United States
can ask for no better partners
indo-pacific or so much of our shared
future will be ridden the UK U.S and
Australia announcing details of the
so-called August deal for
nuclear-powered submarines a new
technology for the Aussie Navy the
biggest single investment in Australia's
defense capability in all of our history
over the coming two decades August will
see the trio eventually develop a new
sub for the UK and Australia a driving
force is the threat posed by China to
Taiwan and in the indo-pacific
Beijing says the plan will trigger an
arms race
that despite China's president Xi
Jinping setting out a vision this week
that his military become a quote Great
Wall of Steel China also alleges that
orcas damages nuclear proliferation
treaties a criticism Biden appeared to
anticipate
not nuclear arm that technology allows
Subs to stay underwater and ideally
undetected for much longer periods such
capability would be useful in the Arctic
for the Trio's 5i security Alliance
partner Canada back when Canada was
exploring the idea of having nuclear
submarines in 1980s uh the Americans are
actually quite reluctant to pass on that
technology even to us cost was and is a
factor for Ottawa 2. Australia is
committing more than 300 billion dollars
over 30 years I don't really see much of
an appetite to include us at some point
along the way to you know have ourselves
insert you know yet another order of
summaries into that very fairy type
build a schedule when asked about any
potential Canadian involvement a
spokesperson for the minister of
National Defense told global news that
Canada is investing tens of billions in
domestic defense programs and half a
billion dollars in defense initiatives
in in the indo-pacific region he added
that the minister is in close and
frequent contact with Canada's five eyes
Partners Redmond Shannon Global News
London
if you're one of the thousands of
Canadians waiting for a response to your
complaint about an airline this is news
for you the federal government is
promising 76 million dollars over three
years to help the Canadian
Transportation agency deal with the
record backlog the money is intended to
improve processing complaints and ensure
that Travelers get the money they're
entitled to from the airlines as quickly
as possible
obviously we don't want planes to fly
when when it's unsafe to do so but there
are certain things that are within the
control of the Airlines and we need to
have clearer rules that
that puts the responsibility on the
airlines when it's their responsibility
the federal transport Minister says the
government is working on major changes
to passenger rights Canada's airline
industry has been plagued by staff
shortages and intense demand plus bad
weather the unprecedented disruptions
have led to a flood of air passenger
complaints in the U.S new winter storms
are bearing down on millions of people
on both coasts tonight on the west coast
yet another atmospheric River threatens
to dump Heavy Rain on California adding
to fears of fresh flooding in an area
already drenched in the Northeast a late
winter storm has left hundreds of
thousands of people without power
Jackson prosco has the latest
from west to east both coasts of the U.S
are taking a brutal late winter beating
a classic Nor'easter stalled off New
England dumping more than 60 centimeters
of heavy wet snow making for treacherous
travel on the roads and tricky Landings
at airports this is not the light fluffy
pretty Christmas snow this is going to
come down like a brick and it is that
weight that causes the problem satellite
images captured lightning flashes inside
the core of the powerful storm the snow
coupled with wind gusts nearing 90
kilometers per hour brought down trees
and power lines more than a quarter of a
million homes were left in the dark
across New York and Massachusetts
while ferocious winds and big waves
Flash the coast pushing water inland
raising the risk of flooding I'm just
filling up my bucket getting ready for
tomorrow those 20 inches we're getting
when you live in New England if you're
not prepared you're looking for trouble
trouble has already arrived in
California where flooding is now a major
threat after a soggy winter that has
brought record amounts of rain and snow
my worst fear happened
it happened and now you see what the
devil station can do this is as bad as
it gets a levee breach in the town of
Pajaro submerged homes and led to daring
rescues of stranded motorists flooded
Creeks remain a major threat and the
worst has yet to come
forecasters warn there's a high risk of
excessive rain and catastrophic flooding
across the state in the coming days 30
million people are under flood watch as
another atmospheric river is set to soak
the waterlogged state from coast to
coast in the U.S the final days of
winter could be ones for the record
books Jackson Brosco Global News
Washington
the Ripple effects of two American Banks
collapsing coming up what it could mean
for interest rates here in Canada
there's more Fallout tonight from the
failure of two American Banks Silicon
Valley Bank's parent company faces a
class action lawsuit over the lender's
collapse there are reports the U.S
Securities and Exchange Commission and
the U.S Department of Justice are
investigating as well the ratings agency
Moody's has downgraded its outlook for
the entire U.S banking sector and
gaviola explains why and the impact it
could have on Canada
it was fast and furious customers
withdrew 42 billion U.S dollars from
Silicon Valley Bank in a single day last
week Whispers were growing we were
already you know really putting our ear
to the ground and listening fueled by a
growing Panic online social media and
other digital Platforms in a statement
the head of the U.S House Financial
Services committee called it the first
twitter-fueled bank run the crisis LED
U.S Regulators to seize control of a
second Bank new york-based signature
just Days Later prompting Moody's one of
the big three credit rating agencies to
cut its outlook for the U.S banking
system from stable to negative citing
the rapid deterioration in the operating
environment Moody's also warned
downgrades could be coming for six more
financial institutions in America
impacting credit ratings and borrowing
costs for the banking industry one of
the things that you'll see happen in
investment markets is that they run for
safety the spillover to Canada's tightly
regulated Banks is expected to limited
but fears have fueled an investor flight
to bonds that may reduce mortgage
borrowing costs
and those bonds are directly correlated
to interest rates specifically fixed
interest rates here in Canada
could impact variable rate mortgages too
as investors now expect interest rate
cuts from the Central Bank forty percent
chance that the Bank of Canada may cut
interest rates as early as April and an
even larger percentage expecting an
interest rate cut by the summer time svb
didn't have a banking license in Canada
but it played a role in lending to Tech
startups with Big Ideas this thing is
going to have a tail or a hangover in
terms of how it's going to impact the
tech ecosystem worries remain about the
broader implications for Innovation
after the loss of a long-standing source
of funding at a time when easy money has
dried up Donna all right angavioli in
Toronto thanks
desperation and despair ahead Malawi's
search for survivors after a
record-breaking cyclone
[Music]
this Drone footage shows the scale of
the destruction after a deadly Landslide
on Sunday in manaus Brazil it is the
largest city in the Amazon region eight
people were killed including four
children and 11 houses destroyed above
average rainfall saturated the ground
and made hillsides there unstable and
it's the latest weather disaster for
Brazil dozens were killed in a landslide
in Sao Paulo state in February
in Malawi the search for survivors
continues after tropical storm Freddy
ripped through the southern African
nation over the weekend the official
death toll has now jumped to at least
190 and that number is expected to rise
as rain and severe flooding continue to
complicate rescue efforts the storm
which first made landfall in the region
last month is set to be the longest ever
tropical cyclone in Paris it's not
pretty many streets are covered in piles
of garbage that are growing larger by
the day garbage collectors are on strike
as part of ongoing protests against the
government's deeply unpopular pension
reforms an estimated six thousand tons
of garbage is accumulated since the
strike started a week ago the
government's plan to raise the
retirement age from 62 to 64 is facing
Fierce opposition and protests French
president Emmanuel macron has refused to
meet with the unions and vows the
reforms will go ahead the bill is up for
a key vote on Thursday
a tense situation is building in the
Pakistani city of Lahore as police
attempt to arrest the country's former
prime minister and Maine opposition
leader Imran Khan
[Applause]
hundreds of supporters gathered outside
Khan's compound today trying to stop
police from entering officers fired tear
gas and water cannon injuries have been
reported on both sides Khan has wanted
on allegations of corruption and
terrorism he says he's done nothing
wrong and that the case is politically
motivated
Punjabi Pioneer next how a BC drag queen
is inspiring others while featuring her
South Asian roots
[Music]
drag shows have become the latest
Battleground in culture wars in the U.S
Tennessee has passed a law restricting
drag shows and in more than a dozen
states Republican lawmakers have been
pushing similar bills drag queens in
Canada get hate mail and death threats
too it can be hard to stand up to that
but as nithu garcha reports one Queen in
British Columbia is not letting it stop
her from thriving you know I always knew
that there is something different in me
even as a boy growing up in India doing
drag before understanding what it was I
started cross-dressing and Performing
whenever I would perform I remember
people would start calling me names
there were a few incidents when I was
beaten up it wasn't until moving to
Canada as an international student
Jolene Queen Sloan realized her calling
becoming a Pioneer in the queer space
when I went to the gay bar for the first
time and I saw the drag queens
performing I was shocked and delighted
at the same time because I saw something
that I've been doing since I was a child
that was in 2018.
now she's the one performing every week
while embracing her culture and identity
working on my day job as an early
childhood educator I am making sure that
I am giving that education and exposure
to the children I see julina's Paving
the path for so many people joshna and
her wife Ankit took ungit's parents to
jolene's performance last year it was
their first drag event I think they were
just like in a bit of shock and a bit of
ore and like I could see my mom's face
so changing into a smile and that just
made me think actually why am I so
worried holding my wife's hand
in public it's my wife we married we
should be able to hold our hands you
know especially as
anti-lgbtq2s plus protests in Canada
seem to be on the rise they say jolene's
work is a way to combat hate I feel that
more education we get as a community
whether you're queer or not queer is the
most important thing
Jolene is set to return to India next
month for the first time in seven years
I am really proud to go back and show my
parents what I have become and how
successful it is and how beautiful it is
Jolene says she has drag performances
booked in States across India and dreams
of opening the first gay bar in her home
community in Punjab so more people can
see a reflection of themselves the way
she did
Global News Vancouver
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is mackles Lake near Terra Nova
Newfoundland and Labrador we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
foreign
[Music]